Speaker 1: This is a super interesting short clip
I want to play for you. Ronna McDaniel, the head
of the RNC, the Republican National Committee. She
appeared on Fox News earlier today. And FOX host
Stuart Varney was asking her about the potential
management by the RNC of the Trump DeSantis
primary. That might be coming, but it might not.
We don't know. And run a send this Ronna McDaniel
Ronna to Sanders. Ronna McDaniel straight up
admits that she has no control over that primary.
And one of the things I've talked about is how
damaging to the eventual Republican nominee will
a really ugly primary be? I think to some degree,
a really ugly primary will hurt whoever comes out
on top and faces the Democratic nominee. Ronna
McDaniel admits this is beyond her to control it.
And then she does a little. What about ism?
Speaker 2: How are you going to manage this
clash between Trump and DeSantis?
Speaker 3: Stewart I would be lying
if I said I'm going to be able to manage
this. There's going to be sharp elbows.
There will be a heated primary process.
What I will say is we have to keep our
eyes on the prize. We need to remember that
70,000 people just died of overdoses. Our
border is open, crime is up.
Speaker 1: We of course,
the border is not open. Crime overall is down
and it's significantly higher, as we just
talked about in red states and red cities.
Speaker 3: Our energy is up. Inflation is
killing middle income families.
Speaker 1: Gas prices have come
down significantly. Inflation is
at its lowest point since 2021.
Speaker 3: And this is coming under the
Biden administration. So we can have a
heated primary. But at the end of the day,
we have to come together if we're going to
beat Biden. And that's where I'm going
to be as RNC chair, always focusing on
the end game, which is winning the White House.
Speaker 1: And that's really the question. She
is right about that. At the end of the day, the
question is, how does the Republican Party defeat
Joe Biden or whoever is the Democratic nominee?
Remember, officially, we still don't know who the
Democratic nominee will be. That's the fundamental
question at the end of the day. And my question
is, if DeSantis got out of the way, it would
become obvious Trump will be the nominee. Does
that help the Republican primary by allowing
Trump to start campaigning now in some way?
I don't know if Trump were to be indicted four
times and drop out, and it becomes clear DeSantis
is the leader, or at least that there's going to
be a contested primary not involving Trump. Is
that a better Republican primary for the purposes
of Republicans ultimately winning in November of
2024? My instinct is that a very ugly Republican
primary will dissuade some Republican voters from
coming out in November of 24, but I don't know
how big that impact will be. So my question to
you is let me know in a comment. Send an email,
send a tweet however you want to get in touch.
Does the Republican nominee, whoever it will be,
benefit more from an easy and smooth primary win
or an ugly and extended and contested primary win?
Let me know what you think. We'll do a follow up
soon based on people's reaction. We'll take a
very quick break and be back with much more.